as if we need any last disastrous revelations
about the Trump administration as it ends.
We found out now that the Trump administration,
through its coronavirus stimulus, actually
gave eight hundred and fifty thousand dollars.
Listen to this, to anti vaccine groups.
While the Trump administration publicly claimed
to be pushing vaccination, the Trump administration
gave anti vaccine groups cash.
I guess because they were affected by the
pandemic, it's absolutely and completely insane.
Five prominent anti vaccine organizations
known to spread misleading disinformation
about the virus and vaccines received more
than eight hundred and fifty thousand dollars
from the paycheck protection program.
Of course, making us ask, why are they giving
money to groups that oppose their stated agenda?
The stated agenda of the Trump administration
is vaccines are good and people should get
them.
And yet they gave money to groups saying.
All sorts of dishonest and deceptive things
about the virus and about vaccines, the groups
are the National Vaccine Information Center
should be called the Disinformation Center,
Mercola Health Resources, the Informed Consent
Action Network, the Children's Children's
Health Defense and the Tenpenny Integrative
Medical Center.
OK, these are groups that to different degrees
are anti vaccine and spread anti vaccine disinformation.
Some of these groups have Facebook pages that
have been suspended temporarily or permanently
because they spread disinformation.
Some of these groups aren't allowed to buy
Facebook ads because they spread disinformation.
And for some reason, the Trump administration,
through its PGP program, gave them money.
Who could have guessed that there would be
abuse when a program PPY that was supposed
to have oversight just doesn't.
Oh, right.
That's actually completely predictable.
And one of the stories of the Trump administration
to think about in the future will be Trump
placating and pandering to many lunatic fringes
and tiebacks is just one of them one of the
really important things to understand.
And over the last four years, I've yelled
at anyone who will listen to me about it.
We've done interviews about conspiratorial
thinking.
We've done interviews about how these types
of thinking develop and the overlaps between
people prone to what we call bottomless skepticism.
Skepticism is good, bottomless skepticism
that can never be satisfied that anything
is, as some others say, is not healthy.
And what we found out is that not only are
many Trump followers prone to conspiratorial
thinking, Trump himself has placated and pandered
to many of these lunatic fringe is anti-tax.
We saw that very early in even during the
transition period of Donald Trump.
And we've seen Trump placate all sorts of
other lunatic fringe is, including those who
thought that there were.
I mean, listen, first of all, the so-called
virus skeptics who for months said it's like
the flu that's a lunatic fringe, but also
people with really wacky ideas about how elections
work and what the lies around elections.
And anyway, we've covered a lot of them over
time.
But what one other thing I was thinking of
is, you know, Donald Trump said he considers
himself a wartime president.
He says coronavirus is a war.
He said it was against the China virus.
That's not what we call it.
But he believes that he has been a wartime
president if you give money to the anti vaccine
group during war.
Isn't that treason?
I don't know.
Certainly something to think about, and I
hope my hope is that if the Joe Biden stimulus
happens, I hope that the monitoring and the
regulation and the oversight actually happens
and this money to anti-tax groups would be
just one of many things that hopefully would
be prevented.
We're going to have more, including the inauguration
of Joe Biden on our Instagram, where you can
find us at The David Pakman Show.
Find me on Instagram at David Pakman,